the traditional concept of web
development from ten years ago was page
oriented when you build a website or an
application you would think in terms of
page our pages how many page you need
how they should relate to each other or
cetera every single page may have its
own j/s CSS dependencies or global
dependencies depending on features and
functionality so finally the page may
end up with something like this this
solution is hard to scale because
loading too many scripts can cause a
network bottleneck right the second
option is to use a big JS file
containing all your project code but
this leads to problems in scope size
readability and maintainability and when
you need to deploy the app you have to
copy all of the HTML J's CSS files to a
production environment which might be
dozens or even hundreds of files and
lastly
to host all of your application files
you need the server right which can
manage that the folder structure handle
routes and so on now we are in a
component based web development era as
you can see here each component is a
piece of UI we can build these
components in isolation and then put
them together to create complex uisce
some benefits are it allows for code
reuse it ensures a UX consistency across
a portfolio and it is a state driven and
then package the application and with
the help of bundlers such as web pack
parcells fuse box and roll up those
bunglers are included out of the box in
JavaScript frameworks but you know
what's common among these frameworks is
that the bulk of the work is named
browser few years ago
Jed Smith at Brooklyn mihrab explained
his vision of next-generation UI
framework
he says the apps
you write our direct grabs but the
runtime we have is a tree the Dom so
writing an app should be just writing a
graph and the compiler would figure out
where the dipoles are and rigged up the
Dom event code to make that relationship
consistent across state and then there's
there was this smart guy goes by the
name of rich harris listening to Jed
suddenly he had this Epiphany
frameworks are not tools for organizing
your code they are tools for organizing
your mind
they often help you write better code
but their true value is in the way they
help you structure your code and express
them so what if a framework wasn't a
thing that run in a browser at all what
if it was a compiler my name is Devlin
doodle I am a senior consultant at Mara
I'm here to talk about slope
cybernetically enhanced web apps so what
is this vault what is a radical new
approach to building user interfaces
where's frameworks like react and view
do the bulk of their work in a browser
is well shifts that work into a compile
step that happens when you build your
app and rather than applying techniques
like virtual Dom diffing it's about
writes code that surgically updates the
Dom when the state of your app changes
this book is written by rich Harris of
the New York Times in late 2016 now
Scott is in version 3 so how does is
both work it's what has taken
inspiration from observable in the way
it runs your code but first let me step
back and you know ask you what is
reactive programming this is a reactive
programming from Wikipedia but you know
to make it short reactive programming
has key similarities with the observer
pattern commonly used in Opie I'm
assuming you have encountered pub/sub
design at some some point
to differentiate absorber from
publish/subscribe absorbers are aware of
the subject that is also the subject
maintains a record of the absorbers
whereas publisher subscriber they don't
need to know each other here's a is
spreadsheet reactive programming what
makes spread ship so intuitive when you
make a change you know
a change in a Cell all the cells that
depended on it you know changes a change
to this is what it's about
thus by default is what brings
reactivity to JavaScript itself so now
let's jump you know yeah see how does
this bot work okay so yeah so you write
a normal JavaScript code but you need to
follow certain syntax so yep enhance
JavaScript your code and then when you
run the spec compiler over your code it
compares that code to optimize runtime
instructions so here it is
you were probably saying right now is
this important you know precompilation
can significantly lower the overhead of
a framework so let's check this out take
a look at this is what did away with
this typical scenario because apparently
there's a performance penalty with
frameworks that don't pre-compiled this
is due to compilation translation that
happens on the client side before any of
the actual code up code can be run
and here is our in change detection
let's review how angular react and view
detect changes in their app state
here's angular their angular so dirty
checking one of the performance
characteristics of this is that it is
bound by the cause of what your
computations here here's react
reconciliation performance
characteristics bound by our render and
different costs of dirty subtree arrays
and here's view it's like virtual DOM
Plus dependency tracking performance
characteristics balance you know balance
update efficiency so yeah it's what has
managed to bypass the virtual Dom here
or you know diffing is not free you
can't apply changes to the real done
without first comparing the new virtual
Dom with the previous snapshot it has
unnecessary computation so how does is
well do a change detection is what does
change detection differently here
it's about component code will be
compiled into vanilla JavaScript
with code detection already in place
okay so this is almost exactly the
update code that's both generates unlike
traditional UI frameworks is well is a
compiler that knows at Build time how
things could change your change in your
app things can change in your in your
app rather than waiting to do the work
at runtime here it generates code like
this so yeah it knows that the only
thing that could ever change here is the
age yeah so this is the whole update
function it generates for this piece of
template here the h1 I am and then age
this boat is able to infer a lot more
about your intention what your
components are trying to do
precompilation and avoiding virtual DOM
what makes this about performant when it
comes to memory allocation here's a J's
framework benchmark this vote is the
first green column here as you can see
here followed by view react and angular
it shows that this bot is the
performance winner among the four but
take it with a grain of salt there might
be an implementation inaccuracy hear
things like development versus
production mode not applying framework
specific optimizations and unintentional
errors of course so we are continuing
and now you only ship the code your app
really needs now let me show you how
small that can be in comparison with
other frameworks this is a benchmark
from free code camp real-world
comparison the front-end frameworks with
bench March 2019 update the debuts can
do it's real world
apropos stories real world means can do
crud send HTTP requests to a back-end
and has authentication what you need to
know here is that the smaller the file
the faster the download and less to
parts so spot is again the winner here
so yes it's bug can produce extremely
lightweight code but why should you care
you know you should care because it can
be extremely fast it uses very little
memory it can be used on embedded
devices you know which you see in the
bit so here in addy Osmani is
presentation at the Osmond is a
developer from Google it talks about
keeping your JavaScript bundles small
especially for mobile devices
why because small bundles improve
download speeds lower memory usage and
reduce CPU costs on mobile you want to
ship much less primarily because of the
network speeds but also to keep train
memory usage low
that's right he also mentioned that
JavaScript execution time is important
for phones with slow CPUs it's also
right you also have to consider due to
differences in CPU GPU and thermal
throttling there are huge disparities
between the performance of high-end here
high-end phones and low-end phones this
matters for the performance of
JavaScript as execution is CPU bound
okay here therefore in the browser that
compiled code executes and then renders
the user interface okay shifting the
load to compile step can also be seen in
other frameworks nowadays like this one
stencil and then the other one is solid
J s of Brian Kearney at O so to try
spell
you need a node.js runtime and PM you
just run NP x digit digit but j s slash
template and the name of the directory
or project go to that directory and PEM
install and then and then run death okay
demo time finally so let me just open up
my base code here and then
weirdest place okay so here I have a
belt here the starter projects got
template and let's check out what's
inside of this package that JSON so yeah
we have scripts here build them start
using roll up here roll up is the
default module bundle of the swap and
you'll notice that most of the NPM
packages are inside these dev
dependencies because this is a compiler
it doesn't need any dependencies during
runtime right but you see this herbs you
like dependencies the dependency for
running the app you know these are here
this public here folder so basically
that's what's inside of the package that
JSON that's close to this so okay so
next is let's run this app
oops what it come from yep and then go
to localhost 5,000 and this is the
default UI of the root component here so
this is the red component let's check
this out okay so in is well this is how
you would write a UI in savate component
there are three sections here part the
script for your JavaScript the template
for view and then the styling here so
yeah it's it's like PJs right
but one thing that you know makes this
different from Vijay s is that you can
do this let's see in Vijay s it has to
be inside this template of parent
element right can do this so it's about
you know you can can basically add two
or more elements here so let's remove
this delete this also nice styling so as
this make it clean slate and let's check
out this main that yes so this is the
app component being instantiated and
that's the word from the hello world
being passed as a props let's delete
this also we don't need that
okay so how do you create a component in
slope so it's right here this naming
convention is pascal case let's write
title and then the extension named spot
just let's say NDC London and here you
just need to import that component then
here just like that
so NDC London so what if I have state
here from the parent or component and I
want to pass it down to the child
component so let's create another
component here
this time let's name it each because
I'll be writing a loop you know looping
control flow here say scrip for each and
here okay so our for array say name
could be say Carlo and this one ID to
name it Richard
so yeah we have an array here and we'll
go into pass it here so here let's
create also an array see name it my
array and then this is how you would
write an if else control flow this if my
array
it's not empty and to close that slash
you know then if else would be Colin
else then just put there empty
and here of course we need to add
something here let's say gonna loop
inside this array here so that means
each in this boat and to close that each
and of course it needs an array here and
then as name could be anything you want
let's name it objects the the index of
this object here inside of the array and
then oops
I can just use it here name right and
then just to create a list with number
and you also need to add a key here just
like in Vijay s in react need the key
that would be any properties that you
know different or unique so that's it so
this should work you think
so each each and here and we need to
pass right pass my array right and then
yep that should work
no forgot something here you know you
you need to to expose this to other
elements or to other components and to
do that you need an access a modifier
but it's not gonna be public
no it's export oh there you go that's it
yes export so we have this feature so
let's create another component and then
you know show you another feature in
this ball so here let's create a form
component script basically if this will
have an input so maybe first name here
and then let's initialize it with empty
string and then welcome first name
it's like that and then the input here
let's try to import again okay
so form form form
okay here it is this is a one-way
data-binding
so in input if you want also to bind it
of course we have to use the attribute
value here right and then just pass this
variable here so we have one-way
data-binding
the problem is of course it's one-way if
we edit this this input here that
wouldn't you know update the text here
so you need all this two-way
data-binding
to do that you just need to prefix this
with bind and then colon that would make
it two-way data-binding simple right
okay another one maybe
okay so let's add some styling here so
you would see how you know we would
stall in stop let's just name it welcome
and then of course the styling should be
here it could be it could be anywhere
you know I mean you can put it here or
here doesn't matter welcome color dark
orange likes well so yeah there you go
there's this styling here as you can see
same as the old HTML CSS but what if if
this is empty how would I you know turn
it to dark again like disable this so
there's the class directive in Bob this
is how you know it's being done welcome
and you just need to pass a boolean here
so we can use this this first name here
right so and then if this empty goes to
you know this thing doesn't get
activated
as soon as you start typing something
here it gets activated so yeah that's a
class directive in its law okay so let's
try another one maybe this one computed
just compute something actually just
adding two variables
okay so food
[Applause]
and then what rent
here and then let's say total expense
just the total X maybe just total enough
there you go
you can put it here it should work let's
try to import that computer computed to
imputed here this is it this one
so okay so what if I want to this
automatically gets updated every time I
change this so let's just use a button
here it's named increase and then to add
a click event in a button just type on
colon and then click and then food get
the current and then add 10 scrap this
and then Greece
okay so how do we make this reactive
because right now this is not reactive
yet so in in is well there's this
JavaScript they build syntax here and
this bot is using it as a reactive
statement or reactive declaration so
basically this is now reactive and it
watches for any changes from these two
variables
so you get this now it's reactive so are
there any angular developers here or
react developers DJ's developers that's
good in in angular you would write it
like this right let me check if I'm
still you know in angular I did a lot of
angular before get together function
this is how you would write it right
Plus this and then rent that's making it
reactive total in UJS you need to put it
inside this computed and then write the
name of that computed value and then
function right
so this is how you would write it in
spell so yep I also did some PJs
application before in native script UJS
and in react in react yes
the first thing that came up from my
mind is using a mob X library this us
more you know it's simpler than creating
your own so in my bags are yeah in
react.js mob X you would write it like
this
computed get total oops good plus right
this is how you would write it in in
react curious so as you can see you know
any of this versus this one you know
actually if you go to this blog website
you know there are three boxes here it
says rest like write less code and truly
reactive so yeah it's yeah I know you
know that it's it's true as you can see
here so let's delete this you don't need
this and what else I can show to you
guys maybe this one from this vault on
mount this is basically Andy on it in
angular in V J's is mounted in rapiest
component did mount or use effect so
here just use it
like so and then let's just replace this
here and then let's turn it 2-0 that
should work
see so this this is a your lap cycle
hook event where you can you know insert
your HTTP requests to your back in the
best place to put there
what else may be transition so let's
create another component
you would need to bring in a spot
transition transition and then fade and
then fly yep for us we also need
something here say visible false
variable and then just you know tell us
this is true show this
so we need a button here you know to
switch the value of this visible to its
opposite value let's name it toggle and
then again on click it's not that hard
to remember okay oh my god see ya think
this is right we see ball then the
opposite of visible right so here okay
just a message like say Superman
and then here you know we can use this
fire and this fade and there's an
attribute that you can access in this
this is the beginning of the transition
of the DUI so you can use fly here then
pass an object that object requires you
to like market position let's say x-axis
I'll be 300 positive and then the
duration just three seconds and then of
course the out here let's use fade and
doesn't need any location just the
duration yeah here it is let's try to
import it here
okay that would be toggle toggle and
then toggle
so let's try it
fly-in fade out another one
fly-in fade out so yeah I'd like to to
show you another one but it would take
me another 30 minutes to explain it and
that the the state management in in spot
so I said what has a built in store you
can use for state management so tomorrow
I'll be having a mini workshop a
two-hour mini workshop please you know
come to my workshop bring your laptop so
you can code along with me we will write
a real world it's about application
you'll be using a navigation here
material UI what else store of course
the store and explain you how it works
what else you writing tests for your
component using it's about testing
library and send HTTP requests we it to
a fake back-end or fake web api so
basically the real would accept
authentication and authorization okay
yeah that would be tomorrow you know
10:00 in the morning so ok so just let's
go here to the spot website I'll just
show you the rest of the the api's here
you can just go here there's the
reactivity here props logic can ok so
tomorrow I'll be also adding these await
blocks events here bindings life cycle
on destroy for you know before leaving
or before destroying the page or closing
the page or moving to another component
or pages and the stores here motion
transitions we just use this animations
using SVG and a lot here actually so
here is the animation of Spock
so you can see you get this out of the
box
print out crossfade flip so guys that is
not useful in component UI libraries
because the author's doesn't don't want
to to make to increase the file size of
the web applications that you know are
built using their component UI libraries
but that's different in spelt in this
vault it's a compiler the authors the
you know the authors they don't care how
many features they they would you know
include in the library because this is a
compiler or the application the the
compile itself will just ignore
everything that are not in use so yeah
that's that's the big advantage of this
well so let's go back to the slide
okay here
okay real-world applications so this
valve is being used for POS systems in
Brazil there's this 200,000 device in
the world that device runs a very old
WebKit on extremely memory constrained
hardware
they tried like a dozen different kinds
of frameworks none of them can be used
because when you press a button it would
respond half a second later of course
the users will be more likely to press
it twice and may end up overcharging the
customer but when they try this but it
works smoothly math lab is a company in
Russia that uses but to build
applications for smart TVs so yeah
here's what you can notice here POS and
Smart TVs are all pretty low powered
devices right and this is a trend that
is only going to increase the new
frontier is the embedded web wearables
Internet of Things in-car entertainment
systems smart home control panels all of
these things that have this place they
need us and a lot of the time those
interfaces will be built we were built
on the web right
what else can but offer server-side
rendering SSR can speed up the first
render of your app and improve its SEO
this is similar to next and Gatsby in
rack nuts in PJs ok so it's about native
you know you can write on mobile you
know mobile application using this book
ok so let me show that to you
I have another idea here obvious code
and this one so this is well on top of
our native script so you can see code
for us sleep
it works smoothly
you know delete are completed so that's
about in native script
okay so and lastly you can also use
spell to build WebGL apps you can go to
these sites about gel demo search so
yeah let's weigh in the bad parts and
the selling points of spelt bad parts
typescript is not supported yet small
community few third-party libraries lot
of dev tools no big company backing very
few jobs are available out there but you
know what angular react and view had
similar history before it's just a
matter of time you can start introducing
this vault it's your boss or your
managers and these are what you need to
enumerate when talking to them selling
points easy to pick up better
performance write less code extremely
small bundles reactive out-of-the-box
right
declarative transitioning and animation
and best for low powered devices
references spell sapper about native you
know and solid Jas another JavaScript
compiler you eye stencil what else
testing library is about testing library
for writing your you know for testing
you know component is what also has a
discord channel if you want to talk to
others what developers around the world
you know you can go to this discord
channel Jeter Jeter and know how to
pronounce that or for roll-up you know
if you have questions or you want to
discuss something about roll-up you can
also go here it's about jobs that
they'll you want to see how often you
know you can see receive jobs or
companies looking for spot developers
you can go here and I highly recommend
you guys to watch rethinking reactivity
of retirees
no he describes about far better than I
ever could and yeah so if you want to
live in Norway you wanna move to Norway
are we're hiring yeah here's my email
and can I get a selfie guys would you so
it's it's gonna be quick so say hi
Thanks okay so I'll hang around for
questions so please don't hesitate to
approach me later thank you guys for
listening hope you like
[Applause]